a beautiful day in anywhere USA and
what's this why it's our friend Elliot
and it appears he's met a woman my oh my
she's even given him her phone number
congratulations Elliot wait a minute
though what if this is like those other
numbers this is a big number dum-dum
you could call the number right in front
of her but that would make you look
petty and lacking of confidence wouldn't
it no here's a tip Elliot miss read the
number back to the young lady if she
corrects you it's real if she says
that's right then you've been duped and
remember Elliot if you have been given a
fake number smile and go on your way
bing boo she won't get you anywhere say
now Elliot is it the night of the big
date already well then it's time to get
ready Oh Elliot
you're not going out like that are you
why look at you imagine showing up to a
date without putting any effort into
your appearance all right Elliot let's
start with your hands how do you make
such a mess hmm
while it's good to be excited Elliot
it's never good to look too eager
let's nix the sign now what to do about
your filthy hands settle down Elliot do
you have a highlighter cover the ink
with highlighter and then wash that well
done Elliot now what about that shirt
let alone an iron why not
[Music]
well then into the shower with you by
hanging your wrinkly clothes in the
bathroom while you shower the steam will
release some of the worst wrinkles
looking good Elliot wait just a minute
mister stick em up partner
for shame Elliot do you know how to
remove those pesky deodorant stains
don't be a crier grab a dryer sheet that
is yes with a few simple hacks even you
can be prepared for a date that I think
you already Elliot have fun
[Music]